>> GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
I WILL BE IN FOR TUCKER FOR THE
HOUR.
KEEP YOUR FINGERS CROSSED.
JUST HOURS AGO HUNDREDS OF
DOCUMENTS FROM TONY FAUCI'S
AGENCY WERE PUBLISHED.
THEY CONFIRM TONY FAUCI'S NIH
FUNDED, GAIN OF FUNCTION
RESEARCH IN WUHAN IS ANY VIRUSES
THAT ARE MORE TRANS MISS I
BELIEVE AND DEADLY.
THE NIH WAS FUNDING DESPITE THE
GENES FROM OTHER CORONA VICE
USES IN THE PROCESS.
THE DOCUMENTS REVEAL THE
RESEARCH HAS CREATED A NEW MORE
POTENT VIRUS THAT CAN EASILY
INFECT HUMANS.
WHAT CAN GO WRONG.
THEY SAY THE DOCUMENTS ARE "A
ROAD MAP TO THE HIGH RISK
RESEARCH THAT COULD OF LEAD TO
THE CURRENT PANDEMIC"
THAT INCLUDES A 2014 PROJECT
FUNDED BY THE NIH IN WUHAN.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE GROUP ECHO
HEALTH ALLIANCE AND A GRANT
AUTHORIZED PETER, OF CAN OWE
HEALTH ALLIANCE TO CONDUCT
"VIRUS INFECTION EXPERIMENTS
ACROSS A RANGE OF CELL CULTURES
FROM ZIT SPECIES AND HUMANIZED
MICE."
WE HAVE KNOWN ABOUT THE GRANT
FOR MONTHS NOW.
THE NEW DOCUMENTS OBTAINED TELL
WHAT WENT ON DURING THE
EXPERIMENTS ON THE MICE.
ACCORDING TO THE PROFESSOR OF
CHEMICAL BIOLOGY AT RUTGERS
UNIVERSITY:
OH, NO.
OTHER WORDS NIH SENT FUNDS TO
PETER TO MAKE CORONAVIRUSES MORE
DANGEROUS.
JUST BEFORE THE PANDEMIC BEGAN
PETER D. WAS BRAGGING HOW EASY
IT IS TO MANIPULATE THE
CORONAVIRUS.
>> YOU'RE A VEROLOGIST, THE
PROTEIN DRIVES WHAT HAPPENS WITH
THE CORONAVIRUS.
YOU CAN GET THE SEQUENCE, BUILD
THE PROTEIN.
WE WORKED TO DO THIS.
CERTAIN BACKBONE OF ANOTHER
VIRUS AND DO SOME WORK IN THE
LAB.
>> AFTER THE PANDEMIC BEGAN
PETER D. STOPPED BRAGGING.
HE ORGANIZED A LETTER TO A
RESPECTED JOURNAL CLAIMING THE
VIRUS DIDN'T ORIGINATE IN A LAB.
IS THE THAT NICE.
TONY FAUCI SITE PUGH THAT LETTER
ON TELEVISION AS PROOF THE VIRUS
WAS NOT MAN MADE.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT THE EVOLUTION
OF VIRUSES IN BATHS AND WHAT IS
OUT THERE NOW THIS COULDN'T BE
ARTIFICIALLY OR DELIBERATELY
MUTATED THE WAY THE MUTATIONS
EVOLVED.
A NUMBER OF QUALIFIED
EVOLUTIONARY BIOLOGISTS HAVE
SAID EVERYTHING ABOUT THE STEP
WISE EVOLUTION OVERTIME STRONGLY
INDICATES EVOLVED IN NATURE AND
JUMPED SPECIES.
>> CASE CLOSED.
THAT'S WHAT TONY FAUCI SAID
PUBLICLY.
WE KNOW FROM PRIVATE E-MAILS HE
WAS CONCERNED ABOUT THE GAIN OF
FUNCTION RESEARCH CAUSING THE
PANDEMIC.
TODAY PUGH UFF SAYS EVERYONE
INVOLVED IN THE RESEARCH WAS
WORRIED ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY.
NOW AFTER REVIEWING THE INTERNAL
NIH DOCUMENTS PUBLISHED ABOUT
THE INTERCEPT ONE BIOLOGIST MADE
THIS ASSESSMENT:
>> SO DOES ECHO HEALTH HAVE THE
RECORDS.
IF NOT HOW CAN THEY RULE OUT A
RESEARCH RELATED ACCIDENT.
SOME OF THIS RESEARCH IS
DANGEROUS ACCORDING TO RICHARD
EBRIGHT.
OCCURRING IN FACILITIES WITH THE
SAME SAFETY PRECAUTIONS AS THE
AVERAGE DENTIST OFFICE.
HERE IS WHAT ONE OF THE
FACILITIES LOOKS LIKE.
>> IT'S NOT A CONSPIRACY TO SAY
THERE WERE LIVE BATS AT THE LAB.
IT'S A FACT.
AS YOU CAN SEE THIS LAB SHOWS
BATS IN A CAGE AT THE WUHAN
INSTITUTE.
YOU CAN SEE THE RESEARCH FEEDING
THE BAT WAY WORM.
IN THIS IMAGE WE CAN SEE
RESEARCHERS CAPTURING BATS AND A
BAT HANGING OFF A RESEARCHER'S
HAT.
IN ANOTHER IMAGE THERE ARE MOUSE
CAGES.
HUNDREDS OF THEM.
WE KNOW THAT THE WUHAN INSTITUTE
WAS USING HUMANIZED MICE FOR
EXPERIMENTS TO SEE WHICH
CORONAVIRUSES COULD INFECT
HUMANS.
>> SOME OF THE MOST
IRRESPONSIBLE VIDEO YOU WILL
EVER SEEN.
IN 2017, TONY FAUCI AUTHORIZED
ANOTHER GRANT IN WUHAN.
NOW THIS SUMMER SENATOR RAN PAUL
OF KENTUCKY ASKED TONY FAUCI
ABOUT THAT GRANT.
>> DR. FAUCI, KNOWING IT'S A
CRIME TO LIE TO CONGRESS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO RETRACT YOUR
STATEMENT --
>> SENATOR PAUL, I HAVE NEVER
LIED BEFORE THE CONGRESS.
I DO NOT RETRACT THAT STATEMENT.
THIS PAPER THAT YOU ARE
REFERRING TO WAS JUDGED BY
QUALIFIED STAFF UP AND DOWN THE
CHAIN AS NOT BEING GAIN OF
FUNCTION.
WHAT --
>> TAKE AN ANIMAL VIRUS AND
INCREASE THE TRANS MISSIBILITY
TO HUMANS.
YOU SAY THAT'S NOT GAIN OF
FUNCTION.
>> THAT IS CORRECT.
SENATOR PAUL, YOU DON KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT, QUITE
FRANKLY.
>> IT NOW APPEARS TONY FAUCI WAS
LYING UNDER OATH.
ACCORDING TO RICHARD EBRIGHT:
TONY FAUCI NOT THE ONLY ONE
CAUGHT LYING.
HE GOT ONE OF THE TOP
EPIDEMIOLOGISTS HEARING ABOUT A
OUT BREAK IN WUHAN MORE THAN TWO
WEEKS BEFORE CHINA DISCLOSED THE
PANDEMIC TO GLOBAL HEALTH
AUTHORITIES.
>> I HEARD ABOUT
DECEMBER 15th, A NEW OUT
PWRAEPL.
>> WHEN YOU FIR